[Music]
welcome back so we're talking about the
singular value decomposition which is
one of the most useful matrix
decompositions in numerical linear
algebra and right now I'm gonna walk you
through how its computed and how its
interpreted in terms of a data matrix X
so we're going to start with the data
matrix X which I'm going to define as a
collection of column vectors X 1 X 2 so
on and so forth up to X M and so the way
I think about this I'm going to give you
a couple of examples of where this
matrix X could come from for example I
could take a bunch of pictures of
people's faces so I could take person 1
and I could reshape that face into a
tall skinny column vector X 1 so let's
say this is a megapixel image then I
would reshape that into a million by 1
column vector X 1 so that's person 1 I
could do the same thing for person 2 and
reshape them into a tall skinny X vector
and so on and so forth up to X M so
let's say I have M people I can get
these M column vectors and in this case
I'm going to say that X K is in our n
where n is the dimension of my
measurements so in this case of a
megapixel image and would be a million
dimensions a million by one vector these
reshaped X vectors and I might have M of
them where M might be you know a
thousand people's faces so a thousand
columns each column has a million pixels
N equals a million okay another example
of this data matrix could be I'll just
draw it again another example I think
about a lot is if these vectors X come
from some physical system some
real-world system in science or
engineering so for example maybe I have
a fluid flow I have some fluid flow past
a circle and I get this nice Karman
vortex treat that we're used to seeing
and maybe I have this flow field as it
evolves in time
okay and again what I can do is I can
take this first snapshot and I can
reshape that into a tall skinny vector X
1 the second snapshot in time so this is
X 1 X 2 dot dot dot up to XM and so in
this case of a physical system now the
columns have the additional
interpretation that they are the state
of the system as it evolves in time ok
so there's lots of ways you can build a
data matrix from either a library of
human faces or from a flow field that's
evolving in time or some other physical
process that you're measuring that's
evolving in time and so what the
singular value decomposition is going to
allow us to do is take this matrix X and
decompose it or represent it as the
product of three other matrices okay
we're gonna have this equals u times
Sigma times V transpose ok and I'm gonna
tell you all about these matrices over
the next few videos I'm gonna give you
what they mean how to compute them and
how they're useful for approximating
this matrix X the things I want to tell
you right now is that the U matrix and
the V matrix are what are called unitary
matrices or orthogonal matrices and
Sigma is a diagonal matrix so I'm going
to write this out in kind of matrix form
again where we have u 1 u 2 dot dot all
the way up to u n this is an N by n
square matrix times this Sigma matrix
and the Sigma matrix is diagonal so I
have Sigma 1 Sigma 2 dot dot dot now
because there are only M columns of X
there will only be M nonzero singular
values and everything else below will be
0 I'll explain this more in a bit and
then the last matrix is this V matrix V
1 V 2 dot dot V M transposed ok so we're
taking our data matrix X and we're
representing it as the product of u
times Sigma times V where these each
have their
intuitive and physical interpretations
of what these columns of U and V mean
and what the entries of Sigma mean okay
so a few things that are important to
note these these columns of u are kind
of they had the same shape as a column
of X so if X is a million by one vector
then the columns of U are million by one
vectors and the way I think about these
these are in some sense in this face
example these would be my eigen my
eigenfaces these are hierarchically
arranged so u1 is somehow more important
than u2 and so on and so forth in terms
of their ability to describe the
variants in the columns of X so in the
case of faces these are eigen faces in
the case of flow fields there I give you
of my original data matrix ax ok so a
couple of things I need to point out so
U and V are unitary and essentially what
that means is that you transpose u
equals the identity and so does uu
transpose ok so it's this so this matrix
u the columns are orthonormal so they're
all orthogonal and have unit length and
they provide a complete basis for all of
our n for this n dimensional subspace or
this n dimensional vector space form the
columns of my data live okay so you have
this property that U is orthogonal and
so it's transpose is its inverse
same thing with V V V transpose equals V
transpose V equals the identity matrix
this one is an N by n this one is an M
by M ok so that's important the other
important thing to note is that Sigma is
diagonal which I've already described
here and it's non negative and
hierarchically ordered so it's in
decreasing magnitude so Sigma 1
is greater than or equal to Sigma 2 is
greater than or equal to Sigma 3 and so
on and so forth is greater than or equal
to Sigma M which is again greater than
or equal to 0 so they're all
non-negative some of them could be 0 but
Sigma 1 is always greater than or equal
to Sigma 2 is greater than or equal to
Sigma 3 and so on and so forth ok so
what this means is that the first column
of U corresponding to Sigma 1 in the
first column of V corresponding to Sigma
1 are somehow more important than the
second columns and those are more
important than the third columns and so
on and so forth
in describing the information in the
data matrix X and the relative
importance of these of these columns of
U and columns of V are given by the
corresponding singular value so that's
what we call these we call the u matrix
the left singular vectors we call V the
right singular vectors and we call this
diagonal matrix Sigma a matrix of
singular values
so each of these Sigma's is a singular
value of X corresponding to the singular
vector U and the singular vector V ok
and this is going to allow us at some
point if some of these Sigma's are
really really small we're going to be
able to ignore them to chop them off and
approximate the matrix X only in terms
of the first few dominant columns of U
and columns of V and the first dominant
singular value Sigma so I'll talk all
about that later but this is kind of an
important concept is that these are
ordered by importance ordered by
importance and that ordering carries
with it the ordering of the the columns
of U and V as well so in the case of
eigenfaces or of a data matrix X
consisting of columns that are reshaped
human faces these column vectors of you
have the exact same size as a vector X
and so these can be reshaped into faces
as well these can be again reshaped into
these eigen faces and so on and so forth
ok so they have a clear interpretation
the entries of Sigma are hierarchically
organized that has a clear
interpretation and these columns of V
also have have an interpretation this
one is a little bit trickier to explain
because it's V transpose so I'm going to
do my best here to to say this in a way
that's clear and actually I'm going to
start in the eigen flows case so if our
data was from a flow field evolving in
time then these would be eigen flows
hierarchically organized the amount of
energy that each of these column vectors
captures of the flow would be given by
these corresponding decreasing Sigma's
and then V one would be essentially the
time series for how this first mode u1
evolves in this flow so each of these
snapshots has a certain amount of u1 in
it and the amount of how that mode
varies in time is given by V so these
are kind of eigen time series
in the case of physics ok these eigen
time series in the case of the human
faces you would basically take this V
transpose this big V transpose matrix so
now it's V 1 transpose V 2 transpose and
so on and so forth and essentially the
first column of this V transpose matrix
would tell me the mixture of all of
those eigen faces the exact mixture that
I have to take of all of those columns
of U to add them up to equal x1 and the
second column of this V transpose matrix
would be the eigen mixture of these
columns that add up to x2 and so on and
so forth of course scaled by by the
singular value so you can think of these
as kind of mixtures of views to make X's
ok so the first column makes x1 the
second column makes x2 and so on and so
forth so very interpretable very kind of
easy to understand the columns of you
have the same size as a column of X so
if these are people these are eigen
people if these are flow fields these
are eigen flow fields and they're
hierarchically organized and arranged
based on these singular values Sigma so
the last things I want to tell you these
are very very easy to compute so in
MATLAB you just say u s v equals SVD of
X I called this Sigma s because I didn't
want to type Sigma but that's you signal
V equals the SVD of X it's just as easy
in Python and R and almost every other
language it's also guaranteed to exist
that's really important it's guaranteed
to exist
and it's also unique up to flipping the
sign of these vectors I can make this
negative u1 and this negative v1 and
nothing changes but up to that this is
unique and it's guaranteed to exist okay
good so we're gonna talk in the next few
videos about how you actually compute
these matrices use Sigma and V again how
we interpret U and V as essentially
eigenvectors of correlation matrices
between the rows and columns of X and
then we are going to be able to use the
singular value decomposition to
approximate the data matrix X to build
models to do linear regression principal
components analysis I could for example
build models on these eigen time series
if I have a physical system we're going
to talk about all of that soon thank you